bill Livingston Cleveland Plain Dealer
columnist bill was a year ago
Cleveland down 3-1 I had Gian and I
asked you how morale was how's morale
this year down three oh well pretty
somber because no one's ever come out of
a 300 set in the NBA in any series at
any time you know it's it's over I think
the players probably know it's over
maybe the old we don't want them to
celebrate and our house thing will
enable me to win enable them to win a
game Friday but you know that I think
they're real shot to get back in the
series was certainly last night and I
agree entirely with what you were saying
by the way you know I think Duran is one
of the three best players in the league
there's no question when along with
Kawhi Leonard and LeBron I know I'm
probably a little bit prejudiced
although I was very hard on him when he
left there the way he left with LeBron
but I think LeBrons number one and you
can argue either one with the other way
for who's number two but you know
LeBrons been other than the eight
turnovers in the first game LeBrons
played great in Kyrie Irving played very
well last night love not so much but
he's been pretty good overall Warriors
are just a great team you know they won
73 games and they added one of the best
players in the world who's taken the
heat today in Cleveland who will take
the heat well they're going to have to
do something given the situation they're
in I I don't know who I would have
suspect they may try to do something
with Kevin Love maybe to get some
younger P you get younger players you
know to put the role players they've
brought in have not paid off really
Korver is having a bad shooting last
didn't ult it's how well against Toronto
Channing Frye never gets on the court I
know they think he's a bad matchup but I
can't believe that he couldn't play
McGee or Pachulia a little bit and go
out and shoot threes a you know and
stretch out their defensive Korver's not
not playing well not making them Darren
Williams is over 11 and although he has
played decent defense you know it's
attempting to say that you can't write
as plus - because there's not a sideways
eight for the - of infinity but you know
this is this is just not a you know this
is a great team they're playing I I know
that last year you know it took a it
took a lot of things people don't want
to hear about it here in Cleveland I
don't really like talking about it
because the Cavs might have one too had
Irving in love been around for the
finals the entirety of the finals and
two years ago but you know it took
draymond Green being stupid and getting
himself suspended on the flagrant foul
limit and curry wasn't a hundred percent
and Bogut got hurt and they didn't have
a rim defender and even then it took to
spot the shot in the stop three of the
greatest plays in Cleveland sports in
probably NBA history all in the last
couple of three minutes of the seventh
game of the finals to win it it was a
miraculous upset and Golden State is
much better this year because of Durant
I wondered this when this series started
that if Golden State was going to sweep
Cleveland that the reaction by
management would be different than if
Golden State won in six games that hey
we're close with them we don't have to
make a big change we're right there
they're on the verge of getting
embarrassed by Golden State and we and
therefore I think it feels like there'll
be a bigger move in the offseason
because they didn't get any wins do you
think that is
and they also trampled through you know
there's just such disparity in the NBA
the Cavs trampled through the East never
should have let a 21-point get away to
Boston they're probably the third best
team in the league but I would say they
are San Antonio is the second best team
and Golden State's just you know now I
think go to state would have lost a
couple games to Kansas City
I'm Kansas City I don't know where that
came from I've shortened to San Antonio
because had Leonard not got hurt I
certainly think they would have lost the
opener but but injuries are part of it -
yeah and I don't think Griffin I don't
know whether Griffin's going to stay is
the GM I doesn't seem like I think you
know he just has to all he can do is
pick up parts like Frye and core
because of the salary situation and they
really can't build a team because it's
all when now before LeBron gets too old
what's worse getting swept by Golden
State or losing in Game seven to the
Cubs all for this year it since the Cavs
have already won one and the Indians now
have the all-time snide of 68 years now
that none of the Cubs have have gotten
off it I would think the Indians you
know Dan it's it's hard for outsiders to
believe and I'm not originally from here
either but the biggest story beyond
question in Cleveland sports history
would be of the Cleveland Browns
everyone the Super Bowl yes still a
football town at heart how many decades
away from happen what make that happen I
won't be around right about it no bill
will you do me a favor and write a
column I'll fill in the names of the
players on the team if I'm still around
if they win the Super Bowl and you're no
longer on this earth so I would be able
to put that column out there for you
sure I don't know whether either one of
us will be around we might not all the
time capsule on that would but I could I
can pass it on to my grandchildren to be
able to call amigo the great party of
Cleveland column yeah yes hey have fun
on Friday night there bill oh yeah it'll
be a joyous says I'm sure well know
everybody's lightly all of them have
celebrated on the other team's court so
you know it would certainly won't be a
surprise if that happens Friday I okay
here's the question we have if you're a
Golden State fan and you have a chance
for history going for no and you have
tickets to Game five back home do you
have the golden the true Golden State
fan is going to say let's go for no
let's make history or they're greedy
selfish want to see it in front of them
and you go five games I think greed
drives sports you know I was very
shocked when it was twenty thousand Cub
fans for Game seven and I really can't
fault Cleveland people who sold their
tickets for what they were going for
- desperate Cub fans you know Golden
State wanted two years ago it's not the
same thing they're just like it's not
going to be that disappointing the Cavs
because they fight because they finally
gave them a champion I would think you'd
want to you know I would think you'd
want to see them win it at home yeah but
I don't think the players feel that well
I every other every time you play
another game it's another chance for
something to go wrong but you make
history if you sweep you go 16 you know
and you do it in Cleveland I think if
I'm if I'm a Golden State we're harder
places to play in the league yeah yeah I
would much rather do it there and just
as that we lost when we're up three
games to one here you go LeBron on your
home turf and we just made history is
the great line there's no question Dan
that the way they were so upset about
letting that three one get away and they
felt like you know I don't think there
is really any defense for green but
because he exceeded the flagrant foul
limit but but they feel like that was
their championship that they let get
away and they don't only want to beat
the Cavaliers they want to grind the
Cavaliers into dust
that's obvious thank you Bill great to
talk to all right Dan that's a Bill
Livingston Cleveland Plain Dealer those
been around a long time seeing the highs
and lows and really really low lows
there in Cleveland the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience